okay so let's continue with our part
three here it's a smaller part but it's
a slightly more advanced it covers
slightly most advanced topics here and
let's just go through it so there's
three main topics here one is the result
sets which is how to deal how to read
certain large data batch processing
which is to insert large data and
database link on cloud so the Sun sets
is basically a data structure that you
can use to read or when you have very
large data sets being read into the
Wolfram language sometimes you can run
into certain problems with Java heap
space and one way to avoid that is of
course to
increase your Java heap space but you
can always take the help of this result
set to only query as much data as you
want and avoid that condition altogether
so here let me show you a quick example
and I already have my connection open so
just a second I'm just gonna adjust my
screen a bit okay so it's just trying to
insert some data like the first check if
I alright so there's a lot of data there
and everything got inserted it's like
ten thousand rows I don't want to see
everything here so I just gotta delete
that so now you have some ten thousand
rows in a in my database and my items
table and sequel result set open will
create a result set or open a result set
and you can do a sequel select of the on
the items table with that so let me just
open that result set and now here are a
few examples wherein I'm selecting five
rows from there or ten rows from there
or the last four rows and that's done
through sequel result set read and then
if you are near done you can close the
result set with sequel resets it closed
let me go to the documentation and show
you a little more detail
okay so we saw a result set open read
and close now apart from that you can
also shift the current position so it's
this is like a cursor so you can shift
the current position of the cursor to
tell
it where the use next start reading from
so for example such shift RS num so
shift the current position by num in the
result set
or you can just tell it to go to a
certain position by using reset go to or
just set the position so set the current
position of the result set and so
there's few examples here that you can
go through and here's few more go-to
examples you can just sell it to go to
the first row by setting it to setting
the position to zero or third row by
setting the position to three you can
also set it backwards by putting a minus
2 or minus one yeah I think that's the
basics of it let me go back to the
notebook yeah so but this is basically
one of the things that you would use
when you have large data sets again
let's go to the next one so what happens
when you want to insert a huge bunch of
data it's usually not that problematic
when you are doing it through sequel
insert because internally though a
sequel insert is built that it it it it
has a batch size set and it will do it
in batches instead of inserting one row
after one row like that which takes a
lot of time so I'm not going to spend
too much time here just go to a special
notebook that we have for batch
insertion that shows an example so I'm
not going to run this notebook because
the example where it shows the
comparison between batch and non batch
the non batch one takes a lot of time so
I'm just going to go through
it's already evaluated so hopefully we
able to follow through so to do this
first fall I increase the heaps heaps
pace because we are showing a non bashed
version also so that's done through
reinstall Java you said JVM arguments to
whatever the heap size you want there
are some sample header names here these
are just for the headers and we have
some data types which is already put
into a list so we have two types here
one is the worker and then the double
now we make a table wherein with just
one line of expression we are making
like a single row here which has the
header and the type that it associates
to and then we just wrap around a sequel
column around each one of those and
provide the data type name and it ident
options here which is this one so this
this just makes the sample making the
sample sequel column just easier so
here's a huge bunch of it and then we
have some sample data that goes into the
table so we create this table using
sequel create table and then we have the
rose that is 50,000 rows inserted in a
non bashed way so we have wrapped this
absolute trimming around it to see how
much time does it take to insert all
that 50,000 row one by one so that's why
you have we have this map here so it's
it's taking one sequel insert inserting
it coming back the second sequel insert
in that way now doing that the number of
rows inserted per second doing that is
66 and when you use sequel insert width
which has the batch batching built in
the number of rows that goes in per
second is a thousand four twenty six for
this example of course so there's less
the timing difference and there's the
difference in the number of rows that
you can get
within one second and if you again let
me just go back to I'm just gonna go to
the patch insertion is such a bad that's
not come home so if you go to the
advanced topics you would be able to see
an entire documentation on this
another thing that's that's not in this
presentation but I think should mention
that here is using this templated form
for inserting values is comes very handy
when you want to insert a lot of data
you prepare your data beforehand and
then use this form in the sequel execute
to insert that huge data here so these
are just the placeholders for the data
here I would definitely recommend going
through this documentation if you are
working with large data ok so that's
about batch insertion and the last topic
that I have here is a database link on
cloud so database link works on
enterprise private cloud it is not yet
available to Wolfram cloud or but
generally what we call the public cloud
or Wolfram cloud com so if you have or
your company or your school has private
cloud Wolfram private cloud installed
you can use database link with it so as
an example like what you can do with it
is I have a survey form here and I'm
running this off our internal private
cloud that we have in the company so I
have a survey form and I'm going to fill
up the form and the data that comes from
that form is going to get inserted into
database now there are certain functions
within the language like one of the gist
document generator that will actually
make a scheduled task to do something
with that data
whenever you schedule it to do so you
can just use scheduled tasks to do it
I'm using document generator because
this will give you an a document like a
report kind of thing using that data so
you can actually see that it's getting
the data from the database processing it
making into a report and then sending it
to you through email in your inbox so
let's see this survey form so this is
the ferry form let's say at the end of
this webinar you get a survey form that
looks like this that is just an example
and I make some selections here and yes
yes and some comments like good webinar
and just submit the form so the farm got
submitted and let's see if I have to so
this is the table where it goes and
there is some data in it which I
inserted earlier and let's go back to
that so using the by setting the cloud
base to the internal cloud and then just
connecting to it
oops I think I get their own password
okay so that gets connected now I'm
setting up a task that uses a template
so this is a template that I created and
this template gets the data from the
database and there are some charts like
bar charts functions in it that will
take the data and create some bar charts
based on the response from the survey so
I'm just going to evaluate that and it
gives me that cloud object so I run the
task and gives me another cloud object
so here you see that notification is set
to also I should get an email with the
report attached and that attachment will
be in the form of a CDF I cannot show
you my email for confidentiality reasons
and so I'm going to show you how the
report looks like this is how it looks
like so totally it shows you the total
number of surveys taken which is six so
basically here I had the code of doing a
select count of one from survey data and
then it gave me that result and this is
the result from the bar chart and so
this is how it looks like and in the
bundle notebook that you're going to get
after the presentation I'm going to put
this template so you can run it for
yourself create this database run it for
yourself and see so this is about the
the comments so whatever comments people
put I just did a I just put a classifier
around it with sentiment analysis so the
overall response of the webinar was
positive or negative you can know that
so this is one of the useful things that
you can do from cloud if you have a
private cloud and it's a very nice
example to show that this brings us to
the end of part three and the end of
this database link here again there are
some resources you will be getting the
material that I have shown you today and
also the notebooks on batch insertion
and the template to create that report